viviane forrester je crois a écrit un
livre qui s'appelait l'horreur
économique dans l'horreur économique
elle dit on est en train de modifier le
système de production de façon à ce que
yannick ayant de plus en plus de gens
privés d'emploi privées de et
l'informatique va décupler sa toutes les
professions du transport vont sauter
puisque maintenant les baigneurs se
conduisent toute seules etc et viviane
forrester poser une question très
intéressante ans elle dit ok tant qu'on
est dans un état démocratique
ces gens qui sont en trop qui n'ont pas
d'emploi qu'on peut pas employer
d'accord puisque on emploie les gens que
quand on peut faire du profit avec dans
ce système
bon on va leur donner des indemnités
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si le régime
bascule et qui cesse d'être une
démocratie qu'est ce que ces gens
deviennent et qu'est ce qu'on va en
faire
et bien ce que dit effectivement todd
c'est que quand on est actuellement dans
une dérive fascistoïde de ce système
c'est à dire que à tout moment ce
système peut dériver
quand on a un gars comme macro et qu'on
lui confie un truc comme la vème
république qui est vraiment vraiment une
saloperie
je veux dire la vème république est un
régime présidentiel qui a été mis en
place dans des circonstances très
particulières pour un général dans une
situation de guerre en algérie
ok c'est une situation qui annule
complètement le parlement le parlement
ne sert strictement à rien c'est qu'à
regarder les 308 marionnettes qui ont
été engagés pour servir de paillasson à
maquereau en un été 2010 est le parlons
c'est un régime présidentiel qui permet
de donner les pleins de pouvoir moi je
dis que macron était éteint à quelques
encablures de faire agir l'article 16 je
dire quand on voit comment il a traité
les gilet jaune qui était un mouvement
extraordinaire un mouvement populaire
magnifique je suis très fier d'habiter
un pays qui a connu les gilet jaune
quand on voit la répression du mouvement
social qui là qu'il a engagée contre
toute forme de manifestation gazés tout
le monde d'entrée cetera
on se dit que ce régime peut basculer
puis c'est pas le seul c'est en train de
bouger comme ça partout dans le monde
vous savez et donc la question c'est que
si ces gens sont en trop les gens qui ne
sont rien comme dirait macro il a eu
cette très jolie formule qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir
[Musique]